today we are going to talk about one of
my absolute all-time favorite pieces of
math it's incredibly fundamental to
engineering to mathematics itself to
quantum mechanics but it's something
that it has a terrible terrible name we
call them complex numbers and worse than
that the things that bring about complex
numbers we call imaginary numbers and
before we get into any of it what I want
to do is start with kind of a poll just
to pull the audience on seeing what you
guys to consider to be well real what do
you consider to exist when it comes to
numbers so we've already been doing a
couple polls in the warm-up animations
but as a a serious poll of so it's one
that's actually going to help me see
where you're coming from before we begin
the lesson here I just want to ask you a
very simple question okay so let's go
ahead and pull it up here pull it on up
and oh for whatever reason it seems like
we're having trouble pulling this one up
hmm okay there we go
took a little delay there among the
values - square root of 2 square root of
negative 1 and infinity which would you
personally consider to really exist
whatever really existing means to you so
in theory if you guys go to three b-1b
co / live you should be able to answer
this and then the statistics based on
your answers are going to start
populating the screen
we won't know what those answers refer
to at the moment all we know is that you
know there's someone who has a lead
another one that's pretty close behind
it and as your answers come in and as
the server is kind of digest them we'll
start to see some of the stats here if
you go to that page by the way 3 B 1 B 2
slash live which redirects to item pool
com what you're going to find is at the
very top you can ask a question on
Twitter and all that's going to do is
basically open up a tweet that's going
to have the hashtag in it locked down
math and that's the way that we're gonna
be doing questions to this instead of a
live chat anytime you have a question or
a comment that you want to you know
insert into the lesson and let that be
part of the discussion it's going to be
pulled up here and it looks like we
already have one this is from Yash Dave
who asks if you could rename the complex
numbers and the so-called imaginary
numbers
- something more intuitive - a name that
conveyed the fact that they have
numerous applications in the real world
what would you name them I couldn't be
happier that you asked - so I have one
friend who seems very passionate about
the fact that we should call them sneaky
numbers personally I'm very fond of
trying to connote spinning and rotation
and this is one of the things we'll talk
about in today's lesson is the fact that
what we call complex numbers what we
call imaginary numbers some of the main
uses that they have come from very
elegant descriptions of how to rotate
stuff and I hope you'll kind of see what
I mean as we as we proceed with that so
on our poll asking you guys which
numbers you consider to really exist
which is of course a subjective question
there's no right or wrong answer here I
am genuinely curious actually how this
breaks down because it's not at all a
strong consensus in one direction it
seems like we've got three top
contenders and then three that are
following pretty evenly behind that so
let's go ahead and take a look what do
you consider to really exist when it
comes to numbers now I can imagine which
ones might be the top two but I'm very
curious about the fact that there's
three all kind of coinciding with each
other there and it looks like I I'm
getting a little bit of a delay before
the reveal so there's kind of this nice
dramatic pause I'll tell you for me
personally I feel like it's very silly
to answer anything that's either it's
not all of them are none of them I can
maybe understand if someone wants to
treat infinity as something different
because it's ill-defined there's lots of
different things that that might mean
but insofar as numbers exist at all if
you consider what a number is to be a
real thing then it would oh man I I
can't believe that we're stalling out on
this one we had fixed it by livestream -
but I guess there's going to be an
oscillation between when it works and
when it doesn't but for me personally
basically anytime that you have a
numerical construct that's helpful in
the real world you know I'd consider
that real I would say that if it's
something that's actually useful in an
application then it is as real as words
are right you're never going to run into
an abstract word like happiness out
there but it has a kind of reality in
our mind
and things like the square root of two
which you can't express as a fraction or
things like the square root of negative
one that don't show up among real normal
numbers you know even if they might seem
a little bit different oh this is such a
shame I'm genuinely curious to see what
your answers are but it's not showing up
for me which I suppose means we'll have
to move on with a lesson but this will
presumably begin working by the end and
we can maybe pull things up again so let
me go ahead and take that away what I'd
like to do for you today basically is
show you the sense in which imaginary
numbers are useful the complex numbers
are useful and from there maybe try to
imbue them with a little more reality I
won't assume that you know what they are
yet it's meant to be a basic primer but
let's just dive right in okay the end by
the way the very end here I want to talk
about two different trigonometric
functions and this is kind of a thing
that we're going to build to two
identities from trigonometry and I
understand that maybe oh these
complicated identities from trigonometry
is not going to be the best way to lure
some people into the understanding oh
yeah complex numbers they're really
useful you're really going to love them
but I do think it's interesting that you
can have a fact that has nothing to do
with complex numbers of the square root
of negative 1 it's just trigonometry
it's everything we were talking about
last time and you can have facts that
are pretty hard to remember I remember
when I was in school and we learned
these addition formulas that if you want
to know the cosine of the sum of two
different angles you know it's this kind
of long thing in terms of cosines and
sines of the original two angles there's
this minus sign that would always trip
people up if you do the same for the
sine it looks similar but there's a plus
sign and instead of having Coast coast
you have cosine it's something that's
very error-prone if you're just trying
to memorize it as it is however if you
come at it with complex numbers this is
not only much less error-prone it has a
very beautiful meaning and it just falls
right out so even if you don't
necessarily believe in the reality of
the square root of negative one you at
the very least have to admit that it's
interesting that it can make other
pieces of math useful that other pieces
of math a little bit more understandable
too and trigonometry is just the tip of
the iceberg if you talk to anybody who's
in engineering anybody who's going into
serious math they'll tell you the
complex
numbers are as weel a part of their work
in their life as real numbers are but
the starting point looks very strange
okay when you start introducing this the
very first thing you do is to say assume
that there's some number I so that I
squared is equal to negative one and I
think through a lot of students there's
maybe one of two possible reactions that
you can have here one is no there isn't
anytime I square a number even if it's
negative if I take negative five for
example and I square it well the
negative times a negative is a positive
so I get 25 any number that you squares
if it's positive
well that just stays positive so it
seems like no matter what when I'm
squaring numbers I always get a positive
number I'm never going to get anything
negative so this does not exist no such
number however if a mathematician comes
and says oh no it exists we've defined
it so that that's the case i think the
other reaction someone can have is hang
on a second you can do that when you
have a problem that you can't solve you
can just say oh I've defined things so
that we now magically have a solution
okay next time I'm having trouble with
my homework and I don't know what the
answer to X is I will be like let X be
the value define to be the answer to
this question so if you're uncomfortable
with this you're definitely not alone in
fact Rene Descartes coined the term
imaginary for these numbers as a
derogatory it was meant to make fun of
the fact that obviously there is no such
answer and it shouldn't be taken as
serious math and then we stuck with that
as a convention and we still call them
imaginary numbers which is genuinely
absurd but that's not the only weird
assumption that we make the second weird
thing that you do when you start talking
about complex numbers is to say there's
not just such a number I but we're going
to give it a home instead of the real
number line which you know all of these
numbers we know when we square them you
can't get a negative what we do is say I
lives in a different dimension I lives
perpendicularly there's one above and
then there's one below negative I and
you can have negative 2i you scale it
however you want
essentially it's proposing that numbers
be two-dimensional and that I has a very
specific home one unit perpendicular
perpendicularly above the real number
line
and okay if we want to extend our number
system I get it maybe it's useful to put
some kind of number up there
but why I right why not say infinity is
the number that sits one unit above zero
or one divided by zero or any other
problem that you couldn't solve before
and you make up an answer to why should
that live there what on earth does the
idea of a point one unit above the real
number line in a separate dimension have
to do with squaring two negative one so
I hope to answer this for you at the
very beginning let's just talk about how
if you're adding numbers that are
two-dimensional like this the rules are
pretty straightforward and it operates
essentially the same as vectors for any
of you who might be familiar with
vectors so let's say hypothetically I
have a number oh I don't know let me
draw one here that's going to be 4 plus
I ok and then I'm going to take a second
number and it's helpful to draw them as
vectors kind of an arrow from the number
zero and this one is going to end up at
negative 2 plus 2i so what I'm saying is
you take the real number negative 2 and
then you move in that perpendicular
direction into the extension of our
number system which again kind of asking
the students to take a lot on faith here
that you're ok to do that that you're
allowed to just pretend that the numbers
extend in this direction if you take
that on faith and you follow hopefully
the fact that it becomes useful helps to
justify why we're doing any of this so
my question for you is simply what
happens when we add these two numbers
now assuming that our question system
has not broken down I should be able to
do this as a proper Pole and let me go
ahead I guess we can first check the
previous Pole ok things seem to be
working so we can take a little step
back in the lesson so I'm just genuinely
curious I want to know how you guys
answered on this one it looks like
there's a there's a back and forth
between answers F and D so f is all of
them saying that all of these should be
considered real and interesting D is the
one that says you should consider to
square root of 2 and negative 1 but not
infinity so there's a good contingent of
you out there who would just reject
infinity as being considered real but
are very comfortable with the square
root of negative 1 that's awesome and
then after that it looks like C people
who reject the square root of negative
fascinating I actually would have
thought that none of them would have
come higher than that none of them is
much lower at a okay so it looks like
we've got a cohort of people who are
comfortable with negative one a large
cohort are uncomfortable with infinity
that's a topic for another day don't
worry about it and then a number of
people who are kind of in that middle
ground of maybe not being super
comfortable with the idea that negative
one might be real let's see if we can
convince you of the difference of that
so for our first much more mathematical
question that's kind of a warm up I just
want to ask you to add these two before
I've taught you how to add them make a
guess at how it might work and I hope
that it feels pretty straightforward
addition is actually the least
interesting part of this but it is it's
a good thing to know when you're
learning about complex numbers it's
definitely one of those operations that
you are going to need to know
unfortunately and you can tell by the
fact that I'm stalling and what I'm
saying here
it looks like the question is still not
loading completely correctly so I'm
going to have a stern word with Cam and
either behind the scenes who have
otherwise built such a beautiful
beautiful interface that's helpful for
this kind of back and forth between you
guys and me I'm gonna have a stern word
with them behind the scenes but in the
meantime let's go ahead and move forward
with a lesson here so I guess I can pull
it up on the just on the piece of paper
and you can follow along at home see
what the addition might be it turns out
to be relatively straightforward if
you're moving four units to the right
and then one unit up and you want to add
the idea of moving two units to the left
and then two units up will you just do
each of those one at a time I'll go
ahead and pull out black here the real
part is going to be those four to the
right then minus two to the left okay
straightforward enough and then the
imaginary part is going to be this one
unit up and then these two units up one
plus two times I so is that one I plus
two I and then when you work that out
four minus two is two one plus two is
three a nice simple introduction here
addition doesn't really have anything
complicated going on which is great that
means that it's one fewer thing for us
to worry about what is so complex about
complex numbers after all well where
everything becomes interesting is when
you try to multiply these numbers
together
so with victors there's not really any
notion of multiplying them to get two
vectors back at least when we're in the
2d plane you have some notions like
cross products and dot products that in
three dimensions can get you something
like it but the rules end up being very
different from that in the number system
you can't really do algebra you can't do
things like assume that if two numbers
multiply to make zero then one of them
has to be zero but complex numbers are
going to end up behaving much like the
real numbers so rules from algebra can
carry over but to understand what that
rotation rule is I know I'm giving
things away what that multiplication
rule is I just want to ask you a simple
question which is basically suppose I
have the point mmm
3 2 okay we're not even going to think
of it as a complex member per se if I
just have some sort of coordinate grid
and I go to the point with x-coordinate
3 and y coordinate 2 what is the 90
degree rotation of this if I rotate it
90 degrees and let's say counter
clockwise counter down geez writing is
difficult counter clockwise
okay now what's lovely about this is we
can basically just turn our paper to
figure it out you say okay if it started
at three two and then I rotate 90
degrees counterclockwise I can just read
that off now as being negative 2 in the
X direction and then 3 in the Y
direction if I had rotated the whole
plane like that so what we've done here
is we've taken 3/2 and then we convert
it to negative 2/3 something which may
be in our original system you know it
looks like this negative 2 and then 3
that's going to be the 90 degree
rotation and what's nice here is that
that rule is very simple and it applies
to any pair that we might have if I took
a pair of numbers a comma B okay and
then I said where is that going to
rotate to if I rotate it 90 degrees it's
going to end up by swapping the
coordinates B a and then making that
first one negative that's a 90 degree
rotation and a nice gut check here is to
say what happens when we do that twice
what if we do that same very mechanistic
operation again twice and I'm gonna go
and take this I swapped the two
coordinates we get a negative B but then
that first one becomes negative so that
was another 90 degree rotation well
what's happened here is we've just made
both of the coordinates negative and
that's reassuring because if I take some
point sitting at a B and then I rotate
it 90 degrees so this will be my initial
90 degree rotation and then another 90
degrees that's the same as 180 degree
worked no I've done that wrong that will
be the same as a 180 degree rotation
which should look like this ignore the
other vector that I drew which is just
taking both of the coordinates and
making them negative negative a negative
B okay so that's reassuring this
operation that does a 90 degree rotation
actually behaves like you would expect
it to now why am I asking you this well
I'm being told that supposedly I'm
allowed to ask you questions again so
I'm gonna have you do your very first
complex product oh look a lot of people
did submit answers very good okay let's
let's grade the complex addition
actually let's let's see if it is
and straightforward to process as I was
hoping it was see how much explanation
is demanded okay so it looks like a
majority of you did get the correct
answer which is 2 plus 3i very good very
good
52 of you answered simply 2 which would
have been the real part of the answer so
maybe just the fact that there's some
vertical component and you need to still
add those vertical components or maybe
those of you who answer to reject the
reality of imaginary numbers so you just
don't even acknowledge that vertical
component some of you answer negative 2
3 which I guess is just making a vestra
swapping up whether you're taking 4
minus 2 or 2 minus 4 so that's
completely understandable we've got 2
plus 3 which is maybe just dropping off
the I so I think maybe a lot of like
simple errors and entry and you know
that happens to all of us especially on
tests is sometimes you know what the
right answer is but then you you forget
a symbol or you swap too so that's all
very good let's go ahead and try our
very first product though like I said so
here because I already talked through
one of the questions we're going to go
ahead and skip ahead of it we know how
to rotate something like 3 comma 2 so
I'm not even going to give you time to
do that and properly grade it stall
stall words words you know they tell me
that it's working and yet it's very slow
for me to progress forward so you know
if I'm not gonna have a stern word with
and you guys can go at them on Twitter
too under the same place that we asked
questions and just say hey Cameron eater
can't you make the live questions work a
little bit better for us ok I think
we're finally there everybody ready
aha wonderful very simple question I
want you to take the number I and I want
you to multiply it by 3 plus 2i and even
though I haven't really talked about the
rules for multiplication what I can say
is pretend like it operates just like it
does for normal numbers you've got
things like the distributive property
where you can distribute this throughout
and then the defining feature of I is
this idea that I squared is negative 1
that's the only special thing you need
to know about that other than that just
treat it like it's a normal number ok
and then proceed forward with the
product wonderful ok so it looks like
we've got quite a few of you coming in
to answer which is always lovely
super exciting for me by the way just
how many people are enthusiastic about
coming and like getting back to the
fundamentals of math in this lockdown
and just you know we're gonna sit back
for an hour and we're gonna learn about
complex numbers and we're actually going
to participant we're actually going to
answer questions as you do it rather
than sitting and passively watching this
is genuinely delightful to me okay this
is this isn't necessarily question I was
expecting to divide the audience
necessarily so unsurprisingly it looks
like we have a very strong majority in
one direction hopefully in the correct
direction but if not that would that
would heavily inform where the lesson
should go so that would be quite useful
and I think that's probably enough time
so I'm gonna go ahead and lock the
answers into this one okay and it looks
like the majority of you answered
negative two plus 3i which is absolutely
correct absolutely correct
so there's two ways to think about this
okay one of them is to walk forward with
the algebra and just do it a little bit
mechanistically okay so if we pull
ourselves up our sheet if we take I
times 3 plus 2 I 3 plus 2 I
it just distributes I times 3 is going
to be 3i I times 2i is going to be 2
times I squared by definition I squared
is negative 1
which means that our final answer is
going to look like negative 2 plus 3i
ok and like I said it looks like a
majority of you correctly did that
product now it's one thing to just walk
through it mechanistically it's another
to step back and say what just happened
geometrically right because what we just
talked through was the fact that if you
want to rotate numbers 90 degrees the
rule is to swap the two coordinates and
then multiply that first one by negative
2 well look it's what's happened here
we've got 3 & 2 those coordinates have
been swapped 2 is now the real part 3 is
the imaginary part but that 2 got
multiplied by a negative 1 because I has
this defining feature of squaring to
become negative 1 so that should give
you some indication that okay
multiplying by I has this action of
rotating things by 90 degrees may
that means that it's not a crazy thing
to do to geometrically position I at a
90 degree angle with the real number
line okay
now to really see why that ends up being
useful it turns out that if you have
that if you have a number that behaves
this way it gives you a computational
mechanism for all of the other types of
rotations that you might want to do that
might not necessarily be ninety degrees
and to show you why this works I'm going
to go ahead and pull up an animation so
let's say we have any number Z and in
this case Z is going to be let's see
where do I have it C is going to be a 2
plus I great and let's say I want to
understand what is multiplying by Z due
to every other possible complex number
what we can go one by one the very first
one that's relatively simple as if I ask
what is Z times one where does it take
the number one
well Z times one is going to be Z so
we're going to take the number one which
I might draw with a little yellow arrow
and we're going to rotate and stretch
that arrow up to the point where Z is
great a kind of trivial fact even though
it's trivial I'm actually going to take
a moment to write that down just so that
we can oh no no that's for the best for
later that is Randy don't you guys worry
about him he'll be coming in in just a
moment so I just want to write down
three crucial facts that are getting an
influence rotation three facts I'll call
it three facts about multiplication the
first two are going to look simple the
third one is going to look innocuous but
it ends up being extremely constraining
so the first one is that if I have any
number Z and I multiply it by one well I
get the number Z back okay
geometrically that means with that we
stretch and rotate that vector one to
get what we want the second one is that
if I take Z times I from what we just
talked about that is the 90-degree
rotation what I might write is like
rotate by 90 degrees the number Z okay
so often our animation what does that
look like let's see we've already
multiplied by one we take I and then
it's going to move to whatever the 90
degree rotation point for Z itself is
okay
two down infinitely many to go and we
know what it does to one we know what it
does to I let's see if we can understand
what Z does to any other possible number
well it turns out those two is really
all we need to work with if we have the
distributive property so the third fact
that's going to look kind of innocuous
is let's say I take this Z and I
multiply it by C plus D times I where C
and D are just any two numbers okay
well this is going to distribute so Z
times C I'm actually going to write that
a little differently I'm going to write
it as C times Z plus Z times D I which
again I'm going to write in kind of a
funny order and write that as D times Z
I now the idea here is what we know
where Z is we also know where Z times I
is so if we're just scaling them up by
some other constants that completely
constrains where we need to go so let me
go ahead and write this down with an
example okay let's say that we go back
here and I want to know what multiplying
by Z does to anything I want to tell I
want to convince you that it rotates all
of the grid in a way that keeps these
lines parallel it keeps them evenly
spaced keeps them perpendicular to each
other
it applies this very constrained rule to
the whole plane and really just think
through any one particular point for
this let's say that we have two times
negative I okay so you move two units in
the positive right direction and then
negative one unit in the vertical
direction well after the product where
that's going to land has to be two times
wherever zealand's plus negative one
times wherever I lands okay and we see
that right it's two times this yellow
vector and it'll be negative one times
the green vector so here even before you
actually work out the product we could
just read off the fact that Z here which
looks like it's two plus I multiplied by
two - I must land on the number five
okay so I actually want you guys to work
this out algebraically because I do
think that it's it's edifying to see
this work in practice right the fact
that we have this geometric rule where
we were just kind of stretching and
rotating and this corresponds to an
otherwise very mechanistic process of
expanding out
some so let's pull back our quiz and I'm
going to it's a little bit silly because
I've revealed the answer but what I
actually want you guys to do here is
take a look at the question which says
what is 2 plus I times 2 minus I and if
you have notes right now if you have a
pencil and paper which I encourage you
to always come to class with I want you
to try working it out do the first
inside/outside last distribution
property just to see mechanistically
what number ends up popping out from
this and then we'll try to see how that
squares with the geometric intuition so
while you're doing that while you're
working that out hopefully on pencil and
paper it looks like we've got a question
from the audience which is is I the same
as I and J the vectors in physics great
question actually that's that's a much
more interesting question than you might
think it is the short answer is no so in
physics you often describe the rightward
direction as I in the up and down
direction as let's go get another one
here let me finish answering the
question first so in physics you often
have this situation where instead of
describing the XY plane you describe the
right vector as I sometimes I hat and
the vertical one as J hat so that's a
separate thing that's how physicists
will describe the right direction of
direction for vectors they're not
necessarily describing complex numbers
totally separate thing what's more
interesting actually is that the reason
that convention came about I believe has
to do with a number system that extends
even beyond complex numbers it's called
the quaternions so with the complex
numbers we introduced something called I
with the quaternions we introduced J and
K these two other numbers both of which
also have squares two negative one as it
happens and the guy who invented them
Hamilton he was trying to describe
three-dimensional space very elegantly
and using the purely imaginary
directions I J and K became a nice way
to do that and I think it's because of
that and his attempts to push that
forward that the conventions slipped
into normal physics to just describe
those as I and J of course that leads to
serious confusion now because if we look
at how physicist thinks of things you
know I is in the right direction
J is in the vertical direction but with
complex numbers I is of course in the
vertical direction so it just makes for
a whole potential mess now what was our
oh no it looks like they took away the
comment oh man there was comment giving
them some sass and then they got
embarrassed so they pulled it away well
it's on screen it's in there for
everyone in the future to see now I
think that's probably been enough time
to work through our a little bit of
algebra here so let's go ahead and grade
it for everyone to see and it looks like
the vast majority of you well I told you
the answer so I'm gonna assume the vast
majority of you are giving the correct
answer Oh interesting
okay so it looks like five five is
correct and that's the most common
answer but then the ones where missed
were three and four and maybe we can try
to understand why three and four would
have been common misconceptions on this
one 69 is close 0 i plus 5 is correct
but I guess just formatted in a weird
way so let's let's go ahead and work
this one out by hand ok it's actually
kind of a pleasant process to multiply
complex numbers because it's so
deterministic you know what you have to
do you know where you start you know
where you're going to end and it's
really just kind of practicing through
it so two times two that's the first
thing that we get and then you take the
inside parts I times two so that's going
to be 2i and then the outside parts
which is negative I times two so that's
negative 2i and then the last part which
is I times negative I so that'll be
negative I squared the defining feature
remember is that I squared is the same
as negative one which means that the
real component of our answer is going to
be 2 times 2 or 4 now minus negative 1
which is plus 1 so that'll be 5 and then
the imaginary parts cancel each other
out that 2i cancels out with a negative
2i so to everyone on the quiz who
answered 5 plus 0 I you know extra
credit to you because that actually is a
hundred percent correct you're even
emphasizing that we're doing this in a
complex context so there's no reason
that you should have been graded
incorrectly on that one however what's
uh what's interesting here those of you
who watch the very first lecture might
notice the same
with difference of squares and this is
effectively a difference of squares type
question and I'm going to guess that
those of you who answered three or four
it probably came down to if you answered
three it would have been because you
took this four and you subtracted one
rather than subtracting negative one
very common mistake no harm in that and
then if you answered four it comes from
forgetting the fact that I squared can
be simplified into a real number so that
you know that very much counts for the
the real component of your final answer
now what's interesting I think is that
that a process of just walking through
the algebra feels very different from
this geometric idea that we had before
of saying multiplying by Z has the
action of rotating and stretching things
and how it rotates and stretches things
is in the way that's necessary to get
the number one to sit on the number Z
and in fact I have a have a good friend
Ben Sparks who is a frequent number file
contributor and as some of you might
recognize and I asked him to whip up a
little geogebra thing because he's just
a geogebra whiz and he actually created
basically the complex number equivalent
of a slide rule that we can play with
here so the way that this is gonna work
is that I can take the number one and
sort of drag it around the plane and as
I do
the rest of the grid moves in the way
that it has to so that the origin stays
fixed in place and then everything else
kind of stays rigid with the exception
of being able to stretch so the way that
you might use this is to say let's say
we want to know what Z times W is well
I'm gonna stretch and rotate the number
one so that it lands on Z and then I'm
going to follow what happens to W which
is now drawn as a a orange vector follow
what happens to W and as it lands there
we can just read off that it ends up at
five
now even though in practice
computationally you would be working it
out with the algebra like we just showed
having in the back of your mind that
this is how they operate helps draw the
connection between complex numbers and
geometry and also trigonometry which
we'll get to in a moment
and that turns out to be a much more
helpful connection than you might expect
so let me go ahead and ask you guys a
second question here which is do to
bring back our helpful little friendly
quiz
given what I just told you about how
complex numbers act I want you to guess
for me it's okay if you don't know it's
okay if you just want to hazard a guess
here
what is the complex number Z so that
multiplying by Z has the effect of
rotating 30 degrees or pi/6 radians
counterclockwise okay so you want to
number Z so that when it's being applied
as an action and you're saying what do
you do to all the other possible complex
numbers the corresponding action is to
rotate by pi/6 radians or 30 30 degrees
okay great we've got a lot of answers
coming in strong consensus around one of
them which is always a good sign let me
show you how I might draw this out if I
were doing things so I would take a look
at a unit circle of some kind and
luckily I have my infinite supply of
unit circles sitting right here and I
would say okay I know that the action
that I want is going to be whatever
takes the number 1 to something that's
the 30-degree rotation of the number 1
it's it's up here whatever complex
number Z this is is going to have the
appropriate action and then from there
it's all of the trigonometry that you
and I were working through last time so
let's look at our answers and let's go
ahead and lock them into place now
before we talk through the explanation
and the correct answer in this context
is d which is cosine of pi/6 plus I sine
of pi/6 congratulations to the majority
of you who correctly answer that very
interesting to me actually is that the
second most common answer was a which is
1 plus PI sixths and I think that's
that's an utterly reasonable guess
actually and let's take a look at why so
if we go back to our friendly unit
circle the number we were going for is
like I said sitting pi/6 radians around
and from everything we talked about last
time the X component of that is the
cosine of PI sixths this is sort of how
cosine is defined and then the Y
component of that is going to be sine of
PI sixths
which means that that number Z that
we're dealing with yeah he's going to
have an X component of cosine of PI
sixths and then an imaginary component
what's in the Y direction of sine of PI
sixths great now that second most common
answer like I said that's very
interesting um if we pull it up it was a
which was 1 plus PI 6 over I let's take
a look at where that sits with a I'll
bring in a second cleaner unit circle
here like I said I've got an infinite
supply they were guessing that it's 1
and that instead of walking PI sixths
around that you walked a straight up PI
sixths okay which is actually quite
close right especially for small angles
if you're just walking straight up
that's not too different from walking
around the circle so if you were to try
to use that number to have the action of
rotating by 30 degrees it would have an
action of rotating by something that's
slightly less than 30 degrees and then
they would stretch things out by
something that's slightly more than a
factor of 1 but it's actually close
which is cool because usually the the
misconceptions might be like very wrong
can computationally but the idea that
the the misconception here was like
computationally quite close indicates
that maybe the geometric reasoning was
lining up with truth which i think is
awesome so to give you an illustration
of how this might actually be used okay
we have a number that has this action of
a 30 degree rotation I want to bring in
of course a friendly PI creature for us
to all think about Mandy so let's say
that I have a PI creature and I'm I
don't know animating a video and at some
point for whatever reason I want that PI
creature to rotate 30 degrees okay I
just want them to rotate there's lots of
ways you can do this one of the most
common ones in computer graphics is to
use matrices which might be a whole
topic for another day but a tactic you
could use is to use complex numbers and
the way this would work is to think of
our PI creature as living in the complex
plane and then in any kind of computer
graphics it's always defined with
various points often these control
points around it and each one of those
control points I would give complex
coordinates to so for example let's say
the the lower right foot here or I guess
Stage Left our right looks like it has
coordinates about one negative three so
that would be given the number one minus
3i and then from what you guys just told
me in answering the question if we want
to take that point and then figure out
where it gets when we rotate 30 degrees
about the origin what I should be
multiplying it by is cosine of 30
degrees by sine of 30 degrees and if
ever you wanted to be convinced that
complex numbers are just as real as real
numbers I think one factor to consider
is that many programming languages have
built into them
complex numbers they are considered as
real as real numbers so what I might do
I can pull up a little Python terminal
for us to play with and complex numbers
if I write something like 3 negative 1
are considered a valid type in this case
they use J I think basically because in
programming parlance I is often used as
an indexing variable so they just go
with J instead that actually matches
with electrical engineering convention
to where they instead of using I for the
imaginary number they use J because
again I was kind of already used so 3
minus 1 J you can just read that as
being the same as 3 minus 1 I and I can
take this number and I can multiply it
by other complex values I don't know
like five for two if I multiply that
it's going to apply the rules of complex
multiplication which basically is just
foiling it out you can think of this as
being the real part is 3 times 4 or 12
minus negative 1 times 2 because
remember that I squared gives us that
negative so that's where the 14 comes
from and then the imaginary part is
going to be that negative 1 times 4
which is negative 4 plus 3 times 2 which
indeed works out to 2 so that's kind of
cool Python seems to be working all of
this out for us and what that means
remember is let's say that we wanted to
rotate our pie creature and let's say
I'm just going to focus on one point
like his foot sitting here which is that
one negative 3 so let's say I define the
foot to be sitting at real part 1
imaginary part negative 3 the rotating
number that I want Z is what you guys
figured out for me we're going to need a
little math for this so let's import
math always a sign that you're about to
have some fun
so we're gonna call Z a complex number
whose real part is the cosine
well I can't write 30 degrees because
this will all be in radians so I'll
write it as PI sixths that's the same
thing as 30 degrees and then the Y is
going to be the sine of that sine of
math PI over 6
great so if we look at its components
the real part is around 0.866
and the imaginary part should be exactly
1/2 but you know often you get a little
numerical error because computers they
can't get all the real numbers perfectly
there's just not enough information in
the universe so they have to have a
little bit of an error there some of you
might recognize that that first part is
the square root of 3 divided by 2 this
is everything we were working out last
lecture for computing things like the
cosine of PI sixths now what this means
for us is if we take Z times foot right
or remember foot was that one negative
3z times foot should tell us where it
goes when you just go through the
mechanistic operation of complex
multiplication this point should tell us
where it lands and violently it's
supposed to land at around 2.30
real-part
and then negative 2.09 as the imaginary
part and indeed when we play that out
and we follow our little foot point here
where does it land now all right it
looks like the real part is a little
above 2 and the imaginary part is a
little less than negative 2 and any
deviation there is probably because the
foot wasn't exactly at that point 1
negative 3 like I said but you can see
what I mean in principle you tell the
computer to do this for every single
point in a given image that you want and
it will tell you where the outputs
should be it'll tell you where the
rotated versions should be so complex
numbers are certainly as real as real
numbers in that respect it looks like
we've got a question from the audience
so let's go ahead and pull that up seal
programmer asks what is the biggest
reason that people use vectors and
matrices to represent rotation instead
of complex numbers that is actually a
very interesting question
I don't know if there's a great reason
actually because if all you're gonna do
is rotate and then potentially scale
things you could have everything defined
in terms of complex numbers in 2d
graphics in 3d graphics that actually
wouldn't work
complex numbers only describe rotations
in two dimensions
however if you want to use a number
system to describe rotations in three
dimensions instead of using matrices you
could use these things called
quaternions which are basically the
complex numbers on steroids and in fact
they expose you to fewer errors like
there's errors that come about when you
try to use matrices for 3d rotation this
thing called gimbal lock talk to any
robot assist or any computer graphics
programmers they'll tell you that gimbal
lock is a real pain and they're
quaternion this sort of complex numbers
on steroids helps to solve that problem
there's a whole other contingent of
people who feel passionate about
something called geometric algebra that
is a whole other topic potentially for
another day but that's that's a really
valid question you've got these two
perspectives on one one possible
operation but if we're just coming at it
from the idea that complex numbers play
a role in other parts of math and in
other parts of engineering I think
thinking of the rotation implications
really helps us see that and this is
particularly visceral for me when I
think in terms of trig identities so if
you remember at the very beginning I
opened up by talking about one
particular trig identity and without
pulling it up again I don't want to go
back and just read off of it I'm going
to ask you one more question which this
is going to be a tricky question this
one will actually take some time to work
through words that I want you to
calculate for me the cosine of 75
degrees okay and let's go ahead and pull
this up as a quiz question so let's pull
up our quiz let's move on to the next
question let's cross our fingers and
hope the cam and either have not broken
anything again and that's all it's
asking what is the cosine of 75 degrees
okay now let me get you started here on
how you might think about it 75 degrees
it's not gonna be based on any triangles
that we might have seen maybe you've
seen a 75 degree triangle and you happen
to remember what its side lengths were
but most people won't have however what
you can do is note that 75 is the same
as taking 45 degrees and then walking
another 30 degrees around okay 45 plus
30 degrees and if I
question is asking us for the cosine of
75 one way to think of it is if you
first walk 45 degrees around and then
you walk another 30 degrees around what
is the x coordinate of that
corresponding point okay so this is
going to have some coordinates XY the
cosine of 75 degrees is asking for the x
coordinate of that now like I said I
think this is this is not easy okay so
it's gonna take some time to work out
and while you guys are working this out
I want you to actually pull out some
pencil and paper and think it through
I'm just gonna pull up a little pause
and ponder music and give us I don't
know I might give us a full 60 seconds
or so to like noodle this one out and
think it through and in the meantime if
you want to ask any questions you know
how to do so through Twitter it's with a
hashtag lock down math and I might go
ahead and take a couple questions while
people try working this out by hand
which again I heavily encourage you to
do even if you're not watching this live
even if you're watching this at a later
date this is the time to say okay I'm
gonna pull out my paper I'm going to try
to think this through and and now I'll
stop talking I'll let you just think
certainly don't feel rushed by the way
even if there are some answers rolling
in right now that is by no means in the
indication that you should have finished
or anything like that
so interestingly we do have a strong
lead but it's not at all a strong second
place so it seems like the the way that
the assuming that the lead is correct
the way that the error errors have
happened is not in a consistent way
which is interesting and that'll be
that'll be fun to dissect once we reveal
what the answers are
let's them let me check if there's any
new questions that have rolled in no ah
which suggests stew me that the two
folks that I have behind the scenes who
were supposed to feed me questions are
probably desperately wrangling with
something item pool related
those of you who have already submitted
an answer or if we think you already
know the answer by the way I want you to
take a moment to seriously guess what
you think the second most common answer
is going to be and where exactly the
misconception could have taken place or
to double check your work you very well
might be one of those sitting in the the
misconception territory which you know
it's it's a lot to work out there's a
lot of different failure points along
the way
all right so with that I'm gonna go
ahead and lock in the answers and if you
wanted to still work it through even if
the answer isn't going to be recorded
that's totally fine we're going to walk
through it in a moment
but I'm gonna lock them in just so that
we can see what the correct answer turns
out to be and the correct answer is D
which it looks like a majority of you
got so that's awesome the second most
common was C which really only differs
by a minus sign and I can I can actually
guess why that's true already so that's
that's interesting
after that is B where there's a square
root of 3 instead of a square root of 2
okay so we have we actually have a
pretty good distribution on this I think
that this shows that this is not at all
an obvious question and can take take a
little bit of noodling to figure out so
if I saw this on a test okay let's say
that someone threw like a high school
math test at me right now and it said
cosine of 75 you know I would know that
in principle I'm supposed to be thinking
of this as in terms of friendlier angles
I know that 45 degrees is a friendly
angle for trigonometry and I know the 30
degrees is what I don't have memorized
though are the addition formulas I
learned them once slipped out of my head
definitely don't have them memorized but
I do know how to read arrive them on the
fly basically the idea is that we take
the complex number associated with a 45
degree rotation which is going to be
cosine of 45 degrees plus I times the
sine of 45 degrees I take that complex
number and I'm going to rotate the
complex number corresponding to a 30
degree rotation so I might even just
pull up yet another unit circle here and
say the one that sits 30 degrees away I
want to multiply it by this number well
what is that number its x-component is
the cosine of that so the real component
is the cosine of 30 degrees and then the
imaginary component
okay the vertical component here is the
sine of 30 degrees which looks like it's
you know the smaller leg of a 30-60-90
triangle which is going to be one half
but we'll work out the numbers in just a
moment
sine of 30 degrees times i and by the
magic of complex multiplication
which I hope isn't magical based on what
we walked through a little bit earlier
the effect that this will have is to
rotate by one and then rotate by the
other so what are these values cosine of
45 degrees is the square root of 2
divided by 2 sine of 45 degrees is the
square root of 2 divided by 2 and if you
want to if you don't remember that and
you want to work it out the way to think
about it is that a 45 degree angle is
going to create an isosceles right
triangle so if we don't know what this
side length is we at least know that
it's the same as the other side length
so if the hypotenuse is 1 we know that x
squared plus x squared is supposed to
equal 1 that's the Pythagorean theorem
that tells us the 2x squared equals 1 so
x squared is the square root of 1/2 and
then that's actually the same as writing
the square root of 2/2 you could also
write it as 1 divided by the square root
of 2 if you want but these are these are
equivalent forms so if you forget you
just draw the triangle it's no big deal
cosine of 30 degrees well if we have our
30-60-90 triangle the long side of that
from everything we talked through in the
last lecture is square root of 3 over 2
square root of 3 over 2 and then the
sine of 30 degrees is 1/2 and now we
just carry out the complex product it's
not exactly a fun prospect maybe but
it's really just for operations so it's
not going to be too bad the real part is
going to be our cosine times our cosine
okay so that's going to end up being our
square root of 2 over 2 multiplied by
square root of 3 over 2
okay I'm also going to package in when
we multiply both imaginary parts okay
I guess I was a little inconsistent I
wrote I times sine and then sine times I
but it's the same thing so I'm gonna
include that square root of 2 over 2
multiplied by the 1/2 but because each
of them has an I we also multiply it by
I squared which by definition is
negative 1 so we get this negative sign
in here and that's going to be the real
part okay which is actually all we need
we just need the real part and that
gives us
the that gives us the x coordinate of
the where they drop before here we go
if we rotate 45 degrees then we rotated
another 30 the X component of that the
real part is going to be the final
answer so we'll do the sine part in a
moment too when we make it more general
but just for the sake of answering the
question this ends up being root 2 times
root 3 which is root 6 divided by 2
times 2 so root 6 over 4 minus and that
minus sign came about because of the I
squared minus square root of 2 over 4 ok
so all in all that ends up being root 6
minus root 2 divided by 4 and if we pull
up the question I think it's very
interesting that the second most common
answer the the most common mistake you
might say is only different because of
that plus sign and if we look at the
math where that came from as it happens
is the idea that this was a minus sign
which came about from the idea that
there was an I sitting in front of each
sign so the most common misconception
came from maybe forgetting to apply the
fact that I squared is equal to negative
1 at least if you were going about it
using complex numbers which from the
whole context of the lecture of course
we want to so this actually corresponds
to a much more general formula and I
think it's edifying to write out that
general formula for ourselves because
anytime that I've forgotten what the sum
of two angles in trigonometry should be
it's totally ok because you can read
arrive it relatively quickly
if you're comfortable with complex
multiplication and the more math that
you do because it shows up all over the
place you actually get very comfortable
with complex multiplication even if you
like me become very rusty on things like
trigonometric identities but with that
comfort you can very quickly read arrive
what the angles should be or what the
sum some identities should be sign of
data writing and talking at the same
time so remember the way to think about
this is that this first number is what
we get by finding a complex number
that's basically just rotating alpha
around the unit circle if you rotate an
angle of alpha around that's what this
first number is the second number
tells us what you would get if you
rotate an angle beta around so let's say
there's some other angle which I might
write down here the whole angle from the
x-axis would be how should I write it
I'll write it as beta that doesn't
really connote that it's the fall angle
just thing I'll just I'll just do it as
a separate a separate friend over here
beta so I think like when I when I see
these terms cosine alpha plus I sine
alpha I think in my head very visually
of a point on the unit circle in the
complex plane similarly I think of a
point on the unit circle in the complex
plane and I know that multiplying them
together means that the action of one of
them is rotating the other so the final
result we know is going to be the point
that sits alpha plus beta around alpha
plus beta plus I times the sine of alpha
plus beta wonderful but on the other
hand if you go through the mechanistic
foil operation you will get an alternate
expression for the answer and by having
an alternate expression you have an
identity which i think is pretty cool
it's a sign that when you have a
non-obvious relationship like the
algebra of complex multiplication and
the geometry of complex multiplication
you can leverage that non-obvious
relationship to get yourself real
identities okay so how does this work
the real part is going to consist of
multiplying those cosines so we have
cosine alpha times cosine of beta and
then it also consists of the two
imaginary parts multiplied together
because that I squared becomes real I
times sine I'd say I won't write
anything here it'll be that sine of
alpha and then the sine of beta and
because we have an I squared we can
consider that a negative one okay so
it's cosine alpha cosine beta minus it
sort of accidentally started writing a
plus so we're just going to live with
that minus sine of alpha plus sine of
theta sine of alpha times sine of beta
okay obviously it's a lot of algebra but
it is satisfying the idea that you don't
need to memorize this and again when you
do this regularly when you do complex
multiplication regularly you can kind of
see
this pop out we're like oh yeah it's the
the real put the two real parts - the
two imaginary parts that as a pattern is
something you start to recognize and
that when you want the imaginary part of
the product that you take the other two
like in this case it's gonna be I times
sine times cosine so the sine of alpha
times the cosine of beta plus the cosine
of alpha times the sine of theta the
cosine of alpha times the sine of beta
long complicated formula all of that
times I this long complicated formula is
giving you the angle on some identities
and sometimes you can write this out in
a much more compact form this this is
not a commonly used notation and I'll
explain why in a moment but sometimes
cosine plus I sine of something comes
about commonly enough it has this
meaning on the unit circle that it's
written as C is okay in this case C is
of alpha so everything that we just
wrote down could be written more
compactly as CIS of alpha times CIS of
beta is equal to C is of alpha plus beta
okay this is communicating the very
non-trivial fact that complex
multiplication lets us you know lets us
work out rotations in the way that we
want to again that's not standard
notation and I'll explain why there's a
much more standard way to write these
but it's weird so I don't want to just
kind of throw it down there but before
we do that I want to illustrate how you
can do a little bit of magic when you
have this proper intuition for complex
numbers and and how they multiply so let
me pull up our quiz again and let's move
on to another question and this question
asks which of the following values of Z
satisfies Z squared equals I okay so
there's two ways that you can think
about this I'll talk about them both and
I'm just going to give you a moment to
kind of think this one through
and while you work that out let me go
ahead and take a question from the
audience
Achmed Osama asks what is an application
that is impossible to achieve without
complex numbers convince me that they
are needed they're fun to work with
maybe but they made things easier but
can we do without them I would say I
believe yeah you can absolutely work
without them because you can basically
use rotation matrices in place of
complex numbers so it's nice about
complex numbers is that when you're
adding things and when you're
multiplying things you're dealing with
the same type they're both complex
numbers but if you wanted to describe
this all with matrices and vectors and
such when you're adding stuff you'd be
adding vectors but then when you want to
do rotation type actions and stretching
type actions you'd be transferring to
instead dealing with matrices so that's
fine you just have to keep that jumbled
and use them differently I'd be willing
to bet pretty much anything you can do
with complex numbers you could do there
it'll become much less elegant and I
guess one of the one of the main things
that would be just really awkward is the
fundamental theorem of algebra which
we'll talk about in a moment but it
basically says anytime you have a
polynomial of degree n so the highest
term you see is something like X to the
N among the complex numbers it has n
different solutions so that's very
elegant it's very nice to work with it
definitely makes the lives easier of
anyone who's working with things where
polynomials come about to include
matrices and things like I don't want to
like throw around terminology but when
you're computing eigenvalues and such
you find yourself with polynomials often
of high degree and it's nice to have
solutions to them I can conceive of
constructing some kind of way to work
with the numbers where you have like
solutions to all of these where the
solutions are expressed in terms of
vectors and matrices and so maybe the
strict answer to your question is you
could do without them you definitely
would not want to life for
mathematicians and quantum physicists
and really anyone who works with like
linear algebra and polynomials would
just become incredibly awkward so in in
some very real sense they are a natural
construct so much so that even if you
could do without them conceivably you
never would want to it would really make
things quite the pain
so coming back to our quiz here it looks
like again we've got a lot of strong
consensus which is good and let me go
ahead and create this alright so the
correct answer is a it's root 2 over 2
plus root 2 over 2 I it looks like the
majority of you got that and ok so very
interesting is that the second-most
common answer was D that no solution
exists without extending beyond the
complex numbers because the question
we're asking in this context is
basically to take a square root of I so
if you think of oh I is defined to be
the square root of negative 1 I think a
common question is to say you know how
deep does this rabbit hole go okay if we
had to make up an answer to the question
square root of negative 1 do we have to
make up another one for the square root
of I and the square root of that and
just kind of keep extending and
extending and it's interesting and
surprising that once you have I you have
pretty much everything else that you
want at least when it comes to solving
anything that looks like a polynomial ok
so the answer here there's two ways to
think about it one of them is the brute
force way and then one of them is the
more elegant way so the brute force way
looks like this you're reading through
the multiple choices and you just kind
of try them out and in this case when
you try out the square root of 2 over 2
plus square root of 2 over 2 times I and
you square it so we're going to multiply
it by itself I'm going to actually do
this just to illustrate that it's
possible and that it's not super fun
taking root 2 times root 2 for that
first real part is going to give us 2
divided by 2 times 2 so 2 over 4 the
real part will also include the products
of the imaginary parts because of that I
squared so we're going to have root 2
over 2 times root 2 over 2 which like we
just saw well excuse me that was
supposed to be 2 over 4 you can tell
them a little all over the place today
which you know just because sometimes
complex numbers get me excited root 2
over 2 times root 2 over 2 is going to
be another 2 over 4 but this time it's
times I times I so we're going to have a
negative in there yeah that's going to
be the full real part and then the
imaginary part is going to come from the
cross terms
something where there was only one I
included so to over to I times root 2
over 2 it's the same product we're doing
over and over it's always 2 over 4 and
then we're gonna add 2 root 2 over 2
times root 2 over 2 I so we're gonna add
the same thing and I'm not writing the
eyes here because I'm gonna factor it
out okay so the real part involves
subtracting these the imaginary part
involves adding them and indeed when we
subtract them that real part is 0 and
when we add them that imaginary part is
1 so we just get 0 plus I or I and okay
it works but imagine that you looked at
this question and it wasn't multiple
choice right someone asks you to find a
square root of I if the only option you
have is this terrible brute forcing it
seems like a very painful process right
to try every number try squaring it if
this is what you have to do but in an
insane trial and error it would seem
like magic if someone just pulled that
answer out of a hat
but if you're thinking about it
geometrically it's actually a pretty
straightforward question to ask because
what you're saying is we want a number
such that Z squared is sitting where I
is right it's sitting one unit above
well if we know the rotation corresponds
to complex multiplication and that means
what we want is a number that rotates by
45 degrees because if you have a number
that rotates by 45 degrees then when you
multiply by it twice that's the same as
rotating 90 degrees so it gets you up to
I all right well what number is that we
could think of and in terms of sines and
cosines if we want you know this is
going to be cosine of 45 degrees this
vertical part is going to be the sine of
45 degrees and it's root 2 over 2 for
each of them this is something we were
working out just by looking at the the
isosceles right triangle each one of
these is equal to root 2 over 2 so
that's very fun simply by thinking of
the geometry you could pull out of your
hat the fact that the square root of I
where I should say a square root of I is
root 2 over 2 plus root 2 over 2 I
another answer would have been what
happens when you rotate not 45 degrees
but if you were to rotate 40 45 plus
another 180 degrees okay so 45 plus 180
actually gets us 225 degrees all the way
around that's another number where if
you multiply by it twice it'll have the
effect of rotating you a grand total of
360 plus 90 degrees it'll kind of rotate
you all the way around and then an extra
90 so in the same way that most positive
numbers have two square roots you know
square root of 25 is 5 but it's also
negative 5 and in the same way that even
negative numbers like negative one has
two square roots not only is it I but
negative I also satisfies this property
that when you square it you get negative
one even i itself has two square roots
and in general everything except for
zero has two square roots zero you might
consider to have like a double root but
again that's sort of a story for another
time so that's pretty magical and now
let me show you another bit of magic
okay something where again you can come
at a question that seems like it's going
to involve just insane trial and error
but if you're thinking about the
geometry of it you're able to come to a
pretty a pretty meaningful answer
relatively quickly alright what's your
question here the equation X cubed
equals one has one real number solution
x equals one makes sense you keep one
you get one among the complex numbers
there are two more solutions which of
the following is one of them okay
so this time it's actually asking us to
cube some kind of complex number or to
verify that when you cube it you're
going to get one we'll give you some
some time to sort of think about that
and in the meantime let me take a sip of
water and then take the question from
the audience
what do we have you showed that in order
to find the cosine of a sum of two
angles you can multiply two complex
numbers does that mean that if I need
the cosine of a subtraction of two
angles I need to divide two complex
numbers wonderful question
yes yes it does mean that and dividing
by a complex number is actually the same
as multiplying by one in the same way
that dividing by two is the same as
multiplying by 1/2
you basically say 2 has the action of
stretching the number line by 2 1/2 as a
multiplier has the action of squishing
everything down by a factor of 2 that's
kind of the inverse action when it comes
to complex numbers 2 divided by it you
ask what's the inverse action so an
example here might be let's say let's
pull up something here let's say I
wanted to rotate you know negative alpha
that's what I want to do so I'm going to
do like cosine of beta minus alpha or
something like that that number could be
considered the inverse the
multiplicative inverse of what you get
by rotating alpha the other way so up
here we have I'm just going to write it
as CIS
4 cosine plus I times the sine of alpha
the inverse number over here is CIS of
negative alpha and that number is 1
divided by this I could even write it
out over here to say C is the number
that's alpha the way a long and unit
circle is equal to 1 divided by CIS of
negative alpha and vice versa if I took
one divided by CIS of alpha this is
equal to C is of negative alpha now
everyone who knows Euler's formula is
kind of screaming at me that there's an
easy way to see this in terms of
Exponential's which is of course where
we're getting with this but because it's
weird this connection between complex
numbers and Exponential's I don't want
to just throw that down right away I do
want to emphasize that this is this
should all make sense before anything
like Oilers formula enters the picture
if you think of CIS as being what
basically a function to ask where do you
end up if you walk
alpha units around the unit circle in
the complex plane
it's the Opera it's the number that you
can use for for rotating things by alpha
degrees so dividing by it will also get
you rotating the other way but the
overall answer there is the division is
the same as multiplication so that's
absolutely the right instinct you can
derive for yourself the angle what would
you call them the trigonometric
difference formulas if you wanted to
great so I think that's probably enough
time if we punch back to our quiz and
let's tone down the pause and ponder
music here it seems like answers have
sort of stopped rolling in so this is as
good a time as any to grade things so
the correct answer here of the four
options that we were given ends up being
drumroll please negative one half plus
the root three over two times I now I
just want you to imagine for a moment
that if you didn't know any of the
geometry of complex numbers someone asks
you this question and if you were to
able to spit it back decently quickly it
makes you look like a machine
right because you would imagine that the
only way to answer this is to look at
each number and then cube it that you
have to go through and do the whole
first inside/outside last but twice
because you're cubing it for each one of
those and then deduce that answer B
turns out to have this property that we
want geometrically there's a very nice
way to see it so let's go ahead and pull
it up what we want is an action so that
when you do it three times you end up
back at the back at one basically I want
if I were to multiply by this number
three times I end up back at once let me
clear for myself nice new piece of paper
here so just remind ourselves what we're
looking for which is X cubed is equal to
one okay so one such action is the
do-nothing action right if you multiply
by one which does nothing ya do that
three times you end up back at one that
is our real solution the other ones
would be to rotate a third of the way
around the circle okay to rotate 120
degrees or you could rotate 120 degrees
the
which is equivalent to thinking of
rotating 240 degrees around those are
other actions where if you do them three
times it's the same as doing nothing if
I rotate 120 degrees then do that three
times I cube it that's the same as doing
nothing that's how you can read this
equation which I think is very nice and
elegant rather than just trying to plug
in numbers and see what comes out so
using the trig that we learned about
last time this again comes from a
30-60-90 triangle you can see that the
real part is negative one half and then
the imaginary part is the square root of
three over two so even before working it
out I can know with confidence that if I
were to go through the painstaking
process of taking negative one half plus
the square root of three over two and
cubing that I'm going to get back one I
don't have to go through that process to
know that that's going to happen which
is pretty magical this also answers for
us a mystery that we had in the last
lecture if you guys remember what we did
is we pulled up decimals so let's go on
back let's go on over to Chrome let's
open up a desmos tab and let's get rid
of whatever else was going on in here
and what we played with was the idea
that if you take a cosine graph and then
if you square it the shapes look
remarkably similar you have this bizarre
relationship we're squaring cosine looks
like squishing it and more specifically
we were able to play around and say if
you double the frequency of that cosine
wave and then you manipulate it in some
other ways we're going to shift it up
and then we divide it by two this is all
something we did last time we got an
identity between them but this raised an
interesting question what on earth does
cosine of 2x have to do with cosine of x
squared well now with complex numbers we
can actually know the answer we can work
this out we know that if you rotate
around by theta degrees okay if we call
that number Z then when we rotate around
another theta degrees this new number is
Z squared right and Z is what I was
calling CIS of theta which we could
expand out as saying cosine of theta
plus I sine of theta
and we can work out that square nearly
algebraically we take cosine of theta
plus I sine of theta the real part of
that is going to come from two products
of the real part so it's going to be
cosine squared of theta but then also
two parts of the imaginary and because
of that I it becomes negative one so
we'll end up with negative sine squared
of theta and then the imaginary part is
going to come from yeah I might as well
just write this out in full cosine theta
plus I sine I realize I'm kind of
running against the edge which is why I
was hesitant to do this but basically
that cosine squared from comes from
taking the cosine times the cosine the
negative sine squared comes from taking
I sine times negative I sine our
remaining terms are going to be that
cosine plus I sine so cosine theta times
sine of theta and then there's going to
be an I I'll just write it out times I
and then we get exactly the same thing
sine of theta times cosine of theta
times I so sine of theta times cosine of
theta times I which we could factor out
this whole last part ends up just being
two times the cosine of theta times the
sine of theta all right all of that
times I so what we've done here is
basically said there's two ways to think
about cosine theta plus I sine theta
squared one of them is oh of course it
doubles the angle and so that's going to
be cosine of two theta on the other hand
algebraically it's equal to deep breath
cosine squared theta minus sine squared
theta plus two cosine theta sine theta I
now that might seem like a big pain but
the big pain is showing us an identity
it's showing us the double angle
identity so what we found here just to
summarize on the real part is that the
cosine of two theta the real part of
what happens when we rotate by that
is equal to cosine squared of theta
minus sine squared of theta now from
another trig identity that we were
working with last time sine squared of
theta is actually the same as taking 1
minus cosine squared this was the
alternate way of expressing the
Pythagorean theorem so we can get
everything written in terms of cosines
and what we have is now 2 times cosine
pardon the messiness of the handwriting
here by the way 2 times cosine of theta
all minus one that is evidently equal to
the cosine of 2 theta and we could
rearrange that further and see what we
were playing around with in desmos that
this cosine of 2x expression over here
this cosine of 2x expression corresponds
with squaring the cosine this was a
reflection of the fact the cosine
relates two complex numbers which i
think is pretty cool yeah and is the
very last thing that I want to mention I
want to talk about why we didn't why
nobody really uses the CIS notation and
I was saying that CIS of alpha is not
really standard notation when we're
talking about rotating alpha around the
unit circle as a reminder this was my
shorthand for cosine plus I sine the
reason is because what you're always
going to see instead through electrical
engineering through quantum mechanics
through math through all sorts of things
is instead the way that this is written
is actually before I show you how it's
written no no I'll just I'll just show
you how it's written it's it's it's
weird and we're going to talk about it
at length the next time but you imagine
that you're raising something to a power
okay e to the I times alpha now this
obviously makes a lot of people very
uncomfortable first of all if you don't
know about e what is e and then secondly
what on earth does it mean to raise
something to an imaginary power so that
is a full lectures worth of material I
do want to talk about it next time but
just to to give an indication of why
this might not be a totally crazy thing
okay I want you to remember the core
property that we wrote down earlier that
when you rotate alpha around the unit
circle and then when you rotate another
beta around the unit circle this is the
same thing as alpha plus beta which
means our CIS function has this kind of
interesting property that adding the
inputs is the same as multiplying the
outputs so with that I want to ask one
final quiz question to try to relate
this to other functions that you might
be familiar with at this point it might
be halfway obvious where we're going
with this but is the very final question
to cue you up for where we're going to
go next time and maybe appreciate the
relationship at play here and why it's
not that crazy I want you to answer
which of the following functions
satisfies F of a plus B is equal to F of
a times F of B okay
I'm being told by the way that um when I
advanced the questions too quickly it
kind of reveals the answer of the next
one which happened all throughout last
lecture and you guys certainly told me
about it again this is one of those
things we're like this is what happens
with live production we thought we had
fixed that usually you know this is a
very weird process for me because
usually when I make videos you catch
some kind of error so you edit out the
error then you put out the video this is
an experience for me is much more like
alright world here it is raw here are
the errors as they come I hope you enjoy
watching them happen because there's no
editing it does not get clipped out this
is math presentation raw all right so as
we do this it looks like pretty pretty
strong consensus I'll give you a little
bit more time to submit the answers all
right and with that let's go ahead and
take a look so the question is what
function has this property we're adding
the inputs looks like multiplying by the
outputs so 2700 of you correctly
answered the two to the X an exponential
function behaves this way looks like the
most common second answer was a that
logarithms which makes sense there's an
identity in logarithms that looks very
similar it's basically the opposite so
if we were to you know write this out I
might say 2 to the a times 2 to the B is
equal to 2 to the a plus B and when
we're thinking in terms of repeated
multiplication this makes a lot of sense
because one of these is saying multiply
in a copies of two then multiply in B
copies of 2 and the result should be all
a plus B copies of two the rule with
logarithms is exactly the opposite and
it's because logarithms are the inverse
of multiplication on that front
it looks like taking the log of a plus B
ends up being the log of a sorry the log
of a times B multiplied log of a plus
log of B
logarithms is another thing I think
we're going to talk about in a later
lecture of this series so if you don't
know about them don't worry but to those
of you who answered that totally
understandable it's because it's a very
similar property but it's just getting
mixed up whether the outputs are being
added or the inputs are now you'll
notice is how strange this factor that
comes about because 2 to the X is
defined as repeated multiplication looks
very similar to the rule that we found
for complex numbers that sit on the unit
circle that multiplying the outputs is
the same as adding the inputs and that
should be very suggestive that there
might be some kind of unifying theory
between them which of course there is it
has everything to do with why we write
things as e to the I theta which I
actually think is kind of a bad
convention the good thing about it is
that it does make it pretty obvious when
you take e to the I theta times e to the
I beta sorry e to the I alpha that
you're allowed to just add them it
really highlights that fact which
otherwise you kind of have to think
through but maybe that's a good thing
that you kind of have to think it
through and you're not just blindly
applying rules but I'm gonna talk all
about that next time we're gonna dig
deep into Oilers formula a way that you
can try to understand what is this
really saying like computationally it's
not talking about repeated
multiplication so what could you do if
you are on a desert island with a bunch
of paper to just work out by hand the
fact that this is a reasonable
expression all of that is to come next
time so thank you for joining apologies
for being mildly scattered throughout